hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde meine Community also die Luke
Crew also ihr habt mal wieder Quiz ist
für mich erstellt die ich in diesem
Video hier versuchen werde komplett
richtig zu beantworten von daher laber
ich jetzt gar nicht mehr lange im heißen
Brei drum rum und wir starten direkt mit
dem ersten Quiz und zwar dem Quiz für
Gulasch Menschen von Mona aka The Punkt
und los geht's mit der ersten Frage wie
lange am Stück muss man furzen um genug
Energie für eine Atombombe zu
produzieren
ich sag mal 15 Jahre
sechs Jahre dann gib mir mal noch sechs
Jahre Zeit zweite Frage wie viele
blätterpapier muss man essen um seinen
Tagesbedarf an Kalorien zu decken ich
wir gehen mal wieder bitte nicht mehr
auf die Bilder ein das ist einfach
bodenlos ich würde sagen man muss
insgesamt 270.000
[Musik]
falsch wir glauben an dich wie heißt der
Mann vom Monopoly Spiel oh Gott ah ich
gehe da nicht drauf ein ich glaube der
heißt tatsächlich Mister money
rich uncle money back Sommer geht's noch
dümmer wie viele Sorten Kölsch gibt es
oh mein Gott wenn ich die Frage nicht
weiß damit ich kein was schlechter
Kölner
hey ihr seid doch echt am Arsch mit
euren Bildern hier es gibt tatsächlich
25 Sorten Kölsch meine Damen und Herren
no joke das weiß ich
[Musik]
welcher Song ist der auf Spotify am
meisten gestreamte entweder würde ich
sagen blinding lights oder
shape of you blinding lights ist ein
bisschen neu deswegen kann ich mir noch
nicht so ganz vorstellen bettgeist auch
krank und ich glaube shape of you
blinding lights
3,4 Milliarden plays war oder falsch
Fische können überführt zu kommunizieren
definitiv war
[Musik]
oh das war eigentlich ein Joke von mir
aber wir nehmen die richtige Antwort
gerne mit wie lange darf man maximal auf
dem Klo sitzen hey man kann so lange auf
dem Klo sitzen wie man will zehn Minuten
safe
man darf maximal drei Minuten auf dem
Klo sitzen geht es jetzt um um
Arbeitszeiten oder wie vorletzte Frage
fürs erste Quiz was ist die chemische
Formel für einen Furz aber ist das
irgendwie das Furz Quiz oder was ist
tatsächlich m2
boah selber krass gewesen wenn ich das
einfach so direkt gewusst hätte ne und
die letzte Frage was
ist trust
hatte es geht um Blöcke pro Sekunde ich
glaube
boah ich würde sagen
drei Blöcke pro Sekunde nein
4,3 wie man auf sowas kommt ne und wie
man auf sowas kommt frage ich mich jetzt
gar nicht mehr schauen wir uns mal das
Siegerpodest an fünf Leute haben wieder
dran teilgenommen Mall ist auf der 3 auf
der zwei müsste ich dann sage
oder
ich hatte doch fast alles falsch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wo bin ich denn
chillig ich würde allerdings sagen wir
machen direkt weiter mit dem Quiz für
Grundschüler von Jessie Akon unterstrich
LOGI erste Frage wer wird heute das Quiz
gewinnen ich denke wirklich definitiv
ich
ich bin gar nicht mit drin
Chima wird okay wenn Chima das wirklich
gewinnt dann bis zum Hellseher Jessy ein
Bauer hat 16 Schafe fast alle sterben
außer 9 wie viele Schafe bleiben übrig
ich sage da nichts zu
[Musik]
alle sterben außer 9 also hä wie viel
Kilometer kann ein Strich mit einem
einzigen Bleistift gezeichnet werden in
einem einzigartiges Bild mit einem
einzigen Bleistift würde ich sagen nicht
mehr als 8 km das kann doch nicht sein
oh mein Gott ich würde gerne wissen wie
viele Kilometer ich schon in meinem
ganzen Leben geschrieben habe
locker einmal um die Welt kann es sein
dass du dumm bist wahr oder falsch eine
Schnecke ist schneller als eine
Schildkröte
boah ey die Musik Stress mich aber nur
15 Sekunden Zeit eine Schnecke ist
schneller als eine Schildkröte auf gar
keinen Fall
das kann nicht sein es gibt Schildkröten
die können echt richtig richtig schnell
sprinten wie lautet die Lösung ist die
nächste Frage und wir haben eine
Matheaufgabe Punkt vor Strichrechnung
meine Damen und Herren drei durch ein
Drittel ein Drittel passt tatsächlich 9
mal in die 3 9 - 190 + 1 = 1
[Musik]
in Mathe
keiner kann mich irgendwie zerstören
wichtige Frage kommt ja als nächstes bin
ich mal gespannt wie viele Pixel hat ein
4k Fernseher
[Musik]
das ist falsch
es ist komplett falsch
aber ich nehme den Punkt mit meine Damen
und Herren wie viele Regenschirme werden
pro Jahr in der Londoner U-Bahn
vergessen das bin ich das tatsächlich
eine Aufnahme von mir aus London ich
würde irgendwas in der Mitte nehmen
damit ist man meistens ganz gut 80.000
welches Tier kann sich nicht übergeben
warum kommt denn das
[Musik]
Pferde habe ich schon ich habe schon
Pferde kotzen sehen ich glaube
[Musik]
nein kommt deswegen daher dieses
Sprichwort von wegen wenn man irgendwas
nicht glauben kann so ey ich habe schon
Pferde kotzen sehen das kann so mäßig
dann kann das auch passieren war oder
falsch eine Nebenwirkung von Aspirin
sind Kopfschmerzen das war tatsächlich
aspirin ist eigentlich gegen
Kopfschmerzen aber es kann auch
Kopfschmerzen verursachen letzte Frage
wie heißt das Ende vom Schnürsenkel
Schinke Rieke
pinke oder Minke ich glaube stinke pinke
aber die meisten Schnürsenkel sind noch
weiß kommen wir jetzt allerdings zum
Sieger meine Damen und Robin auf der 3
ich sag euch wenn ich mal auf der 1 ist
ne dann ist das hier eine hell-serie
Nancy okay ich muss auf der Eins sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
allerdings auch schon zum letzten Quiz
für heute und zwar den idiotenfragen von
Malin aka
lugi_dr_lauch erste Frage war oder
falsch schildkröten können durch ihr
Poloch atmen das stimmt
ich atme auch durch meinen Arsch Bruder
zweite Frage wie lange dauert es bis die
Erde die Sonne umkreist hat tatsächlich
365 Tage
[Musik]
also dümmer geht's ja glaube ich nicht
löse die Rechenaufgabe also wir müssen
anscheinend wieder hier irgendwie
Mathematik anwenden 30 durch einhalb
sind 60 + 10 sind 70
aber das bisschen tricky mit dem geteilt
durch einen Bruch nein Digger vierte
Frage wenn ein Ball und ein Schläger
zusammen 1,10 Kosten der Schläger 1 €
teurer ist als der Ball wie viel kostet
der Ball 10 Cent
[Musik]
oder ist das wieder eine Scherzfrage
oh mein Gott zum Glück habe ich noch mal
überlegt
weil ich habe mir gerade gedacht wenn
ich 10 Cent angewählt hätte dann wird
der Ball ja schon 10 Cent kosten und der
Schläger 1 Euro teurer also ein Euro 10
damit wir ein Euro 20
wenn der Ball allerdings 15 kostet so
wie ich jetzt schlussendlich ausgewählt
habe und der Schläger 1 € mehr dann
kostet der Schläger 1 € und 5 Cent und
dann so insgesamt 1,10 € sehr gute Frage
Halbzeit meine Damen und Herren fünfte
Frage von zehn kannst du diese Aufgabe
lösen wenn man die Zahlen von 1 bis 100
aufschreibt wie oft schreibt man die
Zahl 9
[Musik]
20 mal das ist falsch den Sekunden
später in 99 sind zwei neuen zwei
Architekten wollen ein Haus bauen womit
fängt alles an das bin ich als Architekt
womit fängt alles an mit A
[Musik]
sehr geiles Chris wenn man um 8 Uhr ins
Bett geht und um 9 Uhr aufsteht wie viel
Stunden Schlaf hatte man dann entweder
eine Stunde
oder hier sind überall so Buchstaben
drin ne
muss ich mir das merken für eine Frage
am Ende ich habe schon er und U gesehen
also wenn ich um 8 Uhr morgens ins Bett
gehe und um 9 Uhr aufstehe dann hatte
ich logischerweise eine Stunde Schlaf
wenn ich allerdings um 8 Uhr abends ins
Bett gehe und um 9 Uhr aufstehe habe ich
13 Stunden heißt es muss eigentlich
beides richtig sein allerdings
wirst müsste es ja dann eigentlich bei
den 13 Stunden 20 Uhr heißt und nicht 8
Uhr deswegen würde ich jetzt einfach mal
eine Stunde sagen
wenn ich hier nicht auf dem ersten Platz
am Ende bin dann weiß ich auch nicht ein
Obsthändler ist 160 groß was wiegt er
Obst
[Musik]
ich hasse euch so toll letzte Frage war
oder falsch Berlin schreibt man vorne
mit B und hinten mit H das ist falsch
und die letzte Frage ich hoffe du hast
dir die Bilder genau angeschaut denn
dann weißt du jetzt genau das
Lösungswort okay wir haben irgendwas nee
Lucio kann sich sein weil wir haben noch
ein Haar Laser Luca kannst auch nicht
sein wir haben wir haben auf jeden Fall
ein Hager doch gerade noch gehabt oder
Minecraft 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
Laser Luca oder Minecraft boah die Sache
ist hat es wirklich was mit dieser
Anzahl an Buchstaben zu tun weil Laser
Luca und Minecraft haben die gleiche
Anzeige ich denn dir einfach mal zu
Minecraft
ey kann ich bitte trotzdem auf den
ersten Platz sein auf dem dritten Platz
haben wir Nancy zweiten Platz belegt
China und Nummer eins muss ich sein wenn
ich Nummer eins bin Video vorbei
[Musik]
[Applaus]